[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle harry et puis de
toute façon c'est pas tous les jours
qu'on tombe sur ce type de bahts surtout
bon marché noir où est mon vote
où est passé mon pote je sais pas
dumas dit que c'était une crise
cardiaque tu m'expliques pour la colonne
pourquoi les briser
ce qui compte pour moi c'est les enfants
il est bas ce sera mieux pour est sans
leur père parce que les bottes vont
finir par remplacer l'homme dans tous
les domaines de notre vie sonia c'est un
pote c'est qu'un bout de métal
vous êtes maintenant identifiée comme
utilisateur principal la famille est
complet
j'ai vu vous travaillez avec des robots
je dois avouer que personnellement je
les aime pas beaucoup
on peut jamais savoir s'ils disent
vraiment la vérité qu'est-ce que tu
serais prête à faire pour ta famille
n'importe quoi